PayPal is one of the most popular online
payment systems in the world it has
nearly 200 million active users who
spent three hundred and fifty four
billion dollars on the platform in 2016
PayPal is in more than 200 markets but
it faces growing competition from other
US companies looking to get into the
financial technology market like Apple
and Amazon dan Shulman is CEO and
president of PayPal dan good morning so
great to have you here Thank You Nora
agreed to be here so I mean it's the
future going to be for all of us where
cash is irrelevant we pay for everything
like through a PayPal or something else
or venmo
well there's been a lot of predictions
of the demise of cash and they've all
been wrong so I don't think you're gonna
see cash disappear but I do think there
are a couple of meta trends that are
going on right now that certainly augur
for the explosion of digital payments of
some form first of all cash is
digitizing so you're writing less and
less checks you're paying it more and
more electronically and really the
number one reason why you're moving
towards digital payments is the
explosion of the smartphone hmm so
you've got a smartphone everywhere now
and for consumers in many ways you have
all the power of a bank branch and the
palm of your hand and for retailers that
everybody is shopping through the mobile
phone so that's redefining the face of
retail and those two trends are going to
create really an explosion of digital
payments what's interesting to me is the
answer to so many questions about what's
going on trends in the world of
technology is the explosion of mobile
phones absolutely it's disrupting one
industry after another and I think
Charlie in the next five years you're
gonna see more change in the financial
services industry then you've seen in
the past 30
lots of result so I'll give you a really
important one it's very important to
PayPal it's very important to me that I
think the smartphone is going to a
native
us to what I call democratize financial
services if you think about it in the
financial services industry there's a
saying that's very true there which is
it's expensive to be poor yeah and many
of the things that we take for granted
around the table like cashing a check or
just paying a bill or sending money to
somebody you love is very time-consuming
you can stand in line for 30 minutes 45
minutes just to cash a check and then it
can cost you anywhere between 2% and 5%
of that check just to get cash back in
your hands think about all the
remittances of people working in the
United States that send I need a family
service you know it's part of the GDP
many countries and very expensive on
average they take 8 to 9 percent of the
of the total amount because of all the
middlemen in that and so I think
technology can cut through that
completely that it should make payments
faster more secure and importantly less
expensive because the typical person
that's underserved by financial
institutions today and that's 2 billion
people in the world over 70 million in
the u.s. they spent 10 percent of their
disposable income on unnecessary fees
and interest and if we can change that
imagine a revolutionary it'd be
revolutionary and we have the
opportunity you mentioned the word
secure yeah we talk every day every week
about hacking how secure is this
infrastructure yeah well I think we
should all be concerned about cyber
security I think it's one of the
pressing issues of our day think about
it everything we do is connected today
you know when you're in an elevator the
dams that hold our water our power grid
the financial system it's all software
based and the key to protection right
now is not necessarily just building
firewalls which are like these you know
hire turrets and deeper moats right it's
basically using data and information to
spot behavior that is Abner
so even if you sign in to PayPal with
your username and password that is only
one of many many attributes we look at
to define whether it's really you
so you're confident here we are
confident but you never can stand still
because the bad guys have a lot of
incentive and the key again is having a
lot of data and turn your door as point
we had three hundred and fifty billion
plus come through our network last year
over six billion transactions we look at
every piece of that data and do machine
learning around it Wow make sure that we
can spot frogs on behavior that is a lot
of deep it's fabulous max and more than
Dan Schulman I didn't know pal Benbow
was part of PayPal that's awesome it's
me everybody loves it yeah that's a
great exploding service for millenniums
exactly right job dan Shulman quickly
moving Stormfront there all right thanks
for your time thank you